FEMALE SPEAKER: Is everybody
excited to be here?
What a good turnout.
Chris and I were just joking.
We're like, sex sells.
[LAUGHING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: So we're so
happy to have Dr. Wendy Walsh
here today.
And I know you guys have been
bombarded with emails as
reminders of why
Wendy is here.
But just to give you guys some
background on her, she's
America's thought leader
on relationships.
And each week on CNN and "The
O'Reilly Factor," she breaks
down the psychology of sex,
love, gender roles, divorce,
parenting, and other
human behaviors.
As host of Investigation
Discovery Network's "Happily
Never After," she guides viewers
through the sometimes
treacherous sides of love.
As resident expert at
datingadvice.com, no subject
is taboo in her popular
advice column.
And as former co-host of the
"Doctors" TV show-- if you
guys haven't seen
it, definitely
check her out on YouTube--
she was nominated for a 2012
Daytime Emmy Award.
And she also lectures on
evolutionary psychology and
human mating strategies at
California State University,
Channel Islands.
She holds a BA in journalism,
a master's degree in
psychology, and PhD in
clinical psychology.
She has authored "The Boyfriend
Test," "The
Girlfriend Test," and "The
30 Day Love Detox."
WENDY WALSH: Thank you.
Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
WENDY WALSH: I don't need to
use a microphone, right?
You guys can hear me all, OK?
Yeah, OK.
It's a little more intimate
that way.
If you hear anything that you
want to tweet, I would be
really, really thrilled if
you would tweet it today.
It's @DrWendyWalsh.
The reason why I called my
lecture the Economy of Sex is
because it's a very provocative
title, and people
immediately think
of prostitution.
But it has nothing to do
with that, actually.
It has to do with the fact that,
anthropologically, we
are here to reproduce, right?
And we have a survival mechanism
to reproduce.
And the big currency for
reproduction, of course, is
obtaining a mate who will give
you offspring that will
survive into the next level.
So that's why I call it
the Economy of Sex.
And I really love that
slide, by the way.
Because how many people have
ever sat on a date and watched
somebody eat their money?
OK, let's start off with a
fun little fun fact quiz.
If you had to guess, what
percentage of American men
aged 18 to 25--
this was a young
person study--
can obtain sex on a
first date-- they
have such an A game.
Why don't you just think the
number in your head for now,
and then we'll go over them.
What percentage of men
in our culture
are considered players?
And here's how this study
defined players-- they've had
at least three sexual
partners a year for
three consecutive years.
That's at least nine partners
in three years.
That's considered a Don Juan.
Number of hook-ups the typical
college student has each year.
Think about it.
Percentage of college students
who are virgins.
And the number of lifetime
sexual partners.
Now, I don't want any men to
talk, because men always know
the correct answers to this,
I will tell you that.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: Men know
the numbers so well.
OK, so I only want to
hear from women.
How many men aged 18 to 25, if
100 of them go out on a first
date with a new woman tonight,
what percentage are going to
obtain sex.
AUDIENCE: 60.
AUDIENCE: 25
WENDY WALSH: 60.
25.
What else I got?
30.
No men talk yet.
OK, guy, give me something.
AUDIENCE: 2%.
AUDIENCE: 5%
WENDY WALSH: There we go!
OK.
it's actually just under 20%.
But again, these are young,
18 to 25-year-old guys.
So it's just under 20%.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: What number
did you say?
WENDY WALSH: Just under 20%.
So it's about a one in five
chance, if you're 18 to 25 and
filled with testosterone and
you've honed your A game as
much as possible.
But the point here is women are
ingesting this idea that
sex happens all the time to
everybody, and they're the
ones that should be complying.
All right, percentage of
men who are players.
They've had at least three
partners a year.
Let's start with women.
These guys have had three
partners a year for three
consecutive years.
Women, what percentage of
our male population?
This study was older.
These were men 18 to 30.
AUDIENCE: 25.
WENDY WALSH: 25%.
AUDIENCE: 65.
AUDIENCE: 50.
WENDY WALSH: 65.
50.
Come on, anybody else?
40?
OK, I want a man to answer.
AUDIENCE: 10.
WENDY WALSH: 10-- that's
pretty generous.
It's 3%.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
WENDY WALSH: Now, remember,
you guys are living
in LA and New York.
It's a whole different world
in LA and New York, right?
[LAUGHS]
OK, number of hook-ups the
typical college student has
every year.
AUDIENCE: What's a hook-up?
WENDY WALSH: Oh,
a hook-up is--
that is the big question,
actually.
Because people use the term so
loosely, and they may mean
that they just met for coffee.
But the truth is a hook-up is
a sexual encounter with no
strings attached and no
expectation of ever seeing the
person again.
AUDIENCE: Five.
WENDY WALSH: Five a year
per college student.
AUDIENCE: One.
WENDY WALSH: One.
AUDIENCE: Three.
WENDY WALSH: OK, the
one is right on.
The average college student
has about one a year.
AUDIENCE: That's the average.
WENDY WALSH: Right, that's
the average.
Right.
The study showed that, in the
same study, when they asked
people what do you think the
typical college student has--
not me, them--
they found that they said
about 80% of the typical
students have at least
two or more.
That's the belief system.
But when they actually ask
people have they had hook-ups,
they found that only 35% of
the students had only one
hook-up in the last year,
and the rest had none.
Percentage of college students
who are virgins in 2013.
Guess, men or women.
Huh?
AUDIENCE: 15%.
AUDIENCE: 30.
WENDY WALSH: It's 25%.
25%.
Human beings begin having
sexual activity usually
somewhere between the
ages of 16 and 25,
and it's a big range.
And the higher one is educated,
the longer they
delay the onset of sexual
activity, because they tend to
put career--
oh, and by the way, religion is
named number three as why
these college students
choose virginity.
Number one is STD, pregnancy,
and then the other is
derailing their career
and education plans.
And then three is religion.
I'm going to save the number
of lifetime sexual partners
until we get to the end
of this lecture.
But I want to say quickly, what
I'm hearing from you is
that you guys are believing
the media mythology that
everybody--
especially the women--
that everybody's hooking up
everywhere, all the time.
And that's actually not the
reality of what's going on.
OK, what we're in right now is
what I call a high supply
sexual economy.
And it's actually related
to the rise of women.
Now, I'm not blaming
women here.
I just want you to understand
that when women rise in power,
sex rises in supply
in our culture.
Now, we know what happens when
women are disadvantaged.
We have enough examples of that
around the world, enough
examples in history.
When women are disadvantaged
and they cannot extract
resources from the environment,
they basically
have to monetize their pussies.
I'm sorry.
We can't put that on
YouTube, can we?
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: So either they
withhold sex, wait till a guy
signs on the dotted line to
support them and their
offspring in a contract called
love and marriage, right?
Here, they don't have a
choice, by the way.
It's not a choice.
When you don't have the ability
to extract resources,
get a job, gainful employment,
the only thing you can hope to
do is hook up to a guy
who will support
you and your kids.
And in order to do that,
virginity is coveted.
We know that in cultures where
women are disadvantaged,
marriage rates go up, more
children are born into
wedlock, virginity is coveted,
and, oh, yeah, prostitution
goes way up.
I used an old-fashioned
prostitute there because the
height of prostitution worldwide
was probably
Victorian England, the most
repressed time for women.
And it was a time of great
economic expansion, when the
middle class was developing
in England.
But it was only a time of
economic prosperity for men.
So women had a choice-- not even
reveal a ankle or, God
forbid, they couldn't get
a husband, or sell it.
And in Victorian England, it
was estimated there was one
prostitute for every 12
men in the population.
That's pretty high--
a lot of competition there.
So we know what happens when
women are disadvantaged.
We know what happens
with sexuality.
And I want you to think a little
bit about what's going
on in the sex slave trade
in Asia right now.
Think about what's going on in
India, China, Thailand, where
women are disadvantaged,
right?
And one interesting thing, a
modern day twist on it, is
that as women are becoming
more educated,
particularly in India--
they're working the
call centers,
they're becoming doctors--
they're retaining
their virginity
because of cultural pressures.
So you've got this population of
women who are now working,
having education, retaining
their virginity maybe until
they're 30, until their wedding
day, because of the
cultural pressures.
And you've got this huge
population of men-- what, 20%
of them who get laid on the
first date-- who can't.
So it gives rise to
more prostitution.
When we have powerful women that
we have right now, what
happens is--
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: --we know that we're
seeing an unprecedented rise
of women in America.
For every two guys that graduate
college, there are
three women.
Women make up 3/5 of graduate
school populations.
The only place we're
50-50 are law
schools and medical schools.
Maybe we're lagging a little
bit in engineering and the
hard sciences-- we're
catching up fast.
So in the aged 22 to 32
population, women are actually
making more than their
male peers.
Because we are now in a world
of information technology.
And guess who are great
communicators?
Hmm.
We are darn good talkers
and good typers.
So all of a sudden, women have
an equal ability, or better
even advantage, to extract
resources from the
environment.
And there are more women
in the workforce
right now in America.
Now, a lot of expensive
men were laid off
during the Great Recession.
And we still need a lot more
heels and stilettos and skirts
in the board rooms, but there
are definitely more women
working than men in
America right now.
So what happens is when women
have their own economic
potential, they don't need
marriage necessarily, so they
put sex out into the culture
in high supply.
Because they can finally just
enjoy the pleasures of their
body, right?
It sounds good, doesn't it?
You know, it does.
It sounds really good, that
women can just make their own
money and have sex with
whoever they want,
whenever they want.
Except three things happen
to men in a high
supply sexual economy.
And this is the first example
in history where we've been
able to actually look at it.
The first is some men
lose ambition.
Historically, hunter-gatherer
men competed against other
young men to extract resources
from the environment so they
could impress women.
Did you know a hunter-gatherer
man could have easily
supported his entire village
on squirrels.
But oh no, he had to go out and
risk his life, get a team
of boys together, pull back a
huge woolly mammoth, because
what would he get?
He'd get access to more women.
He could also display waste,
because there's no way of
refrigerating all that
meat, right?
So he could say, hey, I'm so big
and cool, I can let that
meat just rot in the sun.
Because I know all you ladies
will have your pick, and then
I'll have your pick of you.
By the way, today's woolly
mammoth is called
a Super Bowl ring.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: Same deal.
So when women are making their
own money, there's a small
population, maybe 30% of the
men, who can now sit their
mom's basement until they're 30
playing Xbox and ask women
to text in naked pictures
of themselves.
And then they can go over to her
condo, because she has a
perfectly well-suited Martha
Stewart bed, and they don't
need to do anything.
So that's one problem that
we're starting to see.
There are a host of books about
it. "Failure to Launch"
is one of the big ones about
young men failing to launch.
That's one of the problems in a
high supply sexual economy.
Some others lose the
ability to commit.
Because there is a group of men
who are loving this high
supply sex.
And they're riding this wave
of free sex, because, oh,
guess what?
Men don't have a fertility
window.
Oh, there is no rush.
They can wait until they're in
their 40s, and they can marry
a girl who's in her 20s.
Or they can leave baby
mamas along the way.
They've got lots of choice.
So it's getting harder and
harder for women to get some
men to commit.
I say some, because they
don't all fall.
And the other thing that happens
is plenty of good
guys-- remember the other 97%
that aren't the players--
they feel pressure in a high
supply sexual economy to act
like players.
So you end up not being
authentic with who you are.
AUDIENCE: To me, are
they players?
WENDY WALSH: What?
AUDIENCE: That's New
Kids on the Block.
WENDY WALSH: That is New
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: I wondered if
anybody would recognize that.
I just like the picture.
OK, so those are the three
things that happen to men in a
high supply sexual economy.
But there are also three things
that happen to women in
a high supply sexual economy.
Some women adopt a male
model of sexuality.
Now, this is a good place for
me to stop and explain that
men and women are biologically
a little different.
I love that we're really
politically correct in our
world and we do know that in
our workplace we can be as
equal to extract resources
from the environment.
But I have not met a guy yet
who can breast feed.
I have not met a guy who
can actually grow baby.
And none of you have
fertility windows.
So when you hear me talk about
the differences, don't think
political incorrectness, think
I'm thinking about the
biological reality of
what's going on.
So let's talk about sexuality.
Men and women have sex for
different reasons and in
different ways.
Women, not all women--
OK, don't jump on me--
can fall in love through sex.
Because their body excretes
large amounts of oxytocin, the
female bonding hormone.
There are only two times in a
woman's life where her body
excretes a lot of oxytocin.
It is during breastfeeding, so
that she can have a bonding
experience with her baby.
And it is during
female orgasm.
So there are plenty of women out
there, because of our high
supply sexual economy and our
permissiveness and our media
telling you that everybody's
hooking up, who start hooking
up, and then start
going, whoa, this
doesn't really feel good.
Or they call me and say, why
hasn't he called me back?
And I'm like, but you said
that was just sport sex.
Why do you care if he
calls you back?
But I don't know.
He should still call me back.
Right?
So their body is bonding, and
they're not even aware of it.
Now, men can also fall in love
not necessarily through sex,
but if they are in love with
someone, they can have much
better sex, OK?
But a man can also have sex with
the same woman every week
for six months and not like her
one bit more than he did
that first date.
Because men, biologically, can
separate sex and feelings a
little easier than women can.
Now, we are seeing a group
of women who are able to
disassociate and disconnect
from their biology.
We also see high school students
give birth in the
stall of their prom and didn't
know they were pregnant.
OK, so people can separate
from their bodies.
Now, the other thing that
happens in a high supply
sexual economy is all these
super educated, powerful women
start to look at their male
peers who may not be doing as
well and say to themselves,
well, I'm going to
wait for the CEO.
Because I've got an MBA, and
I'm making $240,000 a year.
Why should I be dating my buddy
from the block who's
working blue collar somewhere?
So what happens is you see this
population of women who
are holding out for a
higher status man.
And sociologists actually call
it the George Clooney effect.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: So we are seeing
this population of women,
there are some behaving
like men.
There are some saying, I'll
settle down when I feel like
it, because I know there
will be a greater guy.
But remember, there's one
population of peer men who are
in their mom's basement.
There's another population
of peer men who are not
committing any time
soon, all right?
So this is a message.
AUDIENCE: The numbers
don't work out.
WENDY WALSH: The numbers
They're losing out.
Because number three is, many
women are losing the freedom
to be mothers.
This is the new feminist crisis
of our generation, and
it is this--
one in five women are losing
the freedom to be mothers.
Because either their fertility
window closes before they can
get a guy to settle down, or
because they believe the
marketing mythology of the
fertility clinics.
In vitro fertilization has not
improved since the 1980s.
It's efficacy is
about the same.
It's about 15% success rate.
The average cost--
I did a little bit of research--
is $13,700.
So for your $13,700, you
have an 85% chance of
failing with in vitro.
But every time a celebrity goes
on the news and says that
they bought a baby or grew an
egg or bought an egg or froze
an egg, everyone gets excited.
Egg freezing-- don't even get me
started about egg freezing.
We have not even thawed out
those suckers enough to know
what's going to happen.
You think autism was the big
diagnosis of our generation?
Wait till you see kindergarten
classrooms filled
with thawed out eggs.
And they're taking $20,000 of
women's hard earned after-tax
money to freeze their eggs.
AUDIENCE: Well, women--
why don't they go for men
who are older than them?
Our windows are different.
And men mature at a
different rate.
So I think there's a natural--
WENDY WALSH: There's lots of
solutions, yeah, but you have
to do it before your 35.
The height of female
fertility--
anybody know?
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: I just had a baby.
AUDIENCE: It is more that
they're losing the choice to
be mothers, not necessarily
the freedom?
To your point earlier that
they're constantly choosing--
WENDY WALSH: Well, they think
they're choosing, but they're
not being given the
full picture.
They're given the marketing of
the fertility clinics that
they can wait.
So many young women think
they can have a baby
until they're 50.
Quick question-- what do you
think the biological height of
female fertility is?
AUDIENCE: 32.
AUDIENCE: 27.
AUDIENCE: 25.
WENDY WALSH: That's
a great example.
You're closer.
It's 20!
It's 20.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I understand.
I thought you said--
WENDY WALSH: The height.
No, the height.
I'm sorry, the height.
The best it gets.
It takes a big decline at 30,
falls off a cliff at 35, OK?
AUDIENCE: That's, again,
the average.
The variety is huge.
WENDY WALSH: Yes, there's
a huge range.
AUDIENCE: Some women lose
it at 28, and some
women lose it at 45.
WENDY WALSH: Right.
One of the women I interviewed
for my book actually had
fertility problems
in her late 20s.
AUDIENCE: This is very complex,
because we go for our
career, and some of us are
choosing to opt out--
WENDY WALSH: This is
the big question.
We're going to get there.
OK, I just want you to
understand that when sex
changes in price, it affects our
families, it affects our
cultures, it affects
everything.
OK, so what happens to both
genders in a high supply
sexual economy?
Many are unknowingly shuttled
onto the sexual mass market.
And so when I hear you guys talk
about these ideas that
people are having--
that players are 25% or 60% of
men, that college students are
hooking up everywhere, I know
you're ingesting the message
of our culture that
sex is cheap.
And sex is not cheap.
A high supply sexual
economy creates a
myth of sexual freedom.
The message it sends to
men is take all sex,
any sex, at any cost.
And the cost to men--
usually, by the way, men don't
read relationship books.
And I'll love you all if
you would read mine.
But they do you call in to radio
shows, especially the
truckers in the middle
of the night.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: And they
do email me a lot.
And I hear from so many
men who tell me, I'm
actually a good guy.
I actually want a girlfriend.
I actually would be happy
to have a family
before I'm too old.
But all these girls are so
sexually aggressive right now,
and I can't get one to stay
still long enough.
So they're being overlooked by
their peers, maybe, because
they're not George Clooney.
And the other thing that
happens, the message to women
is have plenty of not-too-much
sex.
Because we have this
thing called the
sexual double standard.
And I want to explain to you why
the sexual double standard
is actually hardwired in men.
What I tell women all the time
is, the good news is the
sexual double standard has
been completely erased--
but only in the minds
of women.
And it's still very
much alive in men.
And you can sit there and train,
and train, and train
men all you want, but it's a
reflex in them as hard-grained
as our fear of snakes.
Did you know, by the way, I
teach some evolutionary
psychology at my kid's
high school.
And I come with a bag.
I pretend it's moving.
It's got stuff in it.
And I throw a big giant, very
realistic looking rubber snake
into the room.
And the kids scream!
And I go, why are
you so afraid?
And then I take the next
thing out, and
it's electrical cable.
I go, in your lifetime, more
people die of electrocution
than snakebite ever.
But you are hard-wired to
be afraid of snakes.
So you are also hard-wired to
have a double standard.
And here's why.
The double standard, by the way,
is the thing that gives
women demerit points for sexual
experience, and gives
men, woohoo, great, exciting
credit for the same sexual
experience.
So in our hunter-gatherer past,
if a man happened to
hook up with a promiscuous
woman, and he spent his time
getting those squirrels or
woolly mammoths or anything
else for that offspring, he
would risk giving his time,
his resources, and protection
to somebody
else's offspring, OK?
So just to show you that this
fear is very real, in one
inobtrusive study in American
hospitals, they found out that
a full 10% of the babies born
do not match the DNA of the
doting daddy at bedside.
Aw, so women fool around, too.
AUDIENCE: Or maybe the men know
that it's not there, but
they are there anyway.
WENDY WALSH: Or they
may not know.
This was an unobtrusive
study, yeah.
Why do you think those
celebrities run right away for
a DNA a test whenever they get
that bill for the baby.
It's the same thing.
Whether you're bringing them
squirrels or paying an alimony
check or a child
support check.
It's the same thing.
Guys want to know.
And by the way, guys didn't
invent monogamy.
This new research came
out in the last--
I love that more women are
getting into anthropology.
Apparently they're signing
up for that,
too, besides med school.
So the belief was that monogamy
was invented because
women were so frail and
fragile during those
vulnerable years of pregnancy
and nursing that they needed
to have the protection
of a man.
They needed to have
his resources--
OK, first of all, the
hunter-gatherer societies that
exist on the planet today, the
gatherers, primarily women,
bring home way more calories
than the hunters.
The hunters get the glory,
because that
woolly mammoth is big.
But if you just count nuts,
roots, and berries, we're
doing just fine without
you all.
But what happened is women move
because we're gatherers.
So women were the ones
roaming further
and further and further.
And if a man wanted to be sure
that that was his offspring,
he better tag on to her and keep
going after her, right?
So it was actually men who
invented monogamy, they're now
suggesting, because they wanted
to make sure who their
offspring were.
The double standard's around.
It's probably not going
anywhere for
another 100,000 years.
So that's the problem in the
high supply sexual economy, is
that women are loving their
sexual freedom but, at the
same time, astutely aware of
their count, and having
conflicted feelings about
what's going on.
So let's talk about what
is natural mating.
And some of the pictures that
you're going to see here, I'm
thrilled to tell you that
there are a few
hunter-gatherer societies
on the planet today.
And many of them are being-- did
you see the new stuff from
the new tribe they found in
Peru in the last week?
Oh, go online.
Google it.
AUDIENCE: So every one of them,
there will be 100 people
and 300 anthropologists
around them?
WENDY WALSH: Exactly.
Actually, you can't
go near them.
Because there's a rule in Peru
that if you meet any
indigenous people, you
cannot touch them.
You have to go far away.
So most of these pictures--
maybe not this one in
particular, because
they're posing--
are taken with long
range telescopes.
Because they will die from
diseases from us.
They're not ready
to be exposed to
our modern city diseases.
So here's what our families
look like.
We lived in a roving encampment
of maybe 25 to 35
people-- about the size of an
average office work group,
about the size of an
average classroom.
This is a number that works
well for humans.
Most of the people were
related to us.
They were biologically
related.
We lived with aunts, sisters,
cousins, mothers.
We were protected
by our brothers.
Probably the longest male-female
relationship and
the closest one in our history
was brothers and sisters.
Because think about it-- your
siblings are with you your
whole life.
Your parents eventually
die off.
Your mate you meet and
stays for the second
half of your life.
But your siblings are there from
the beginning and end.
So they tend to be very helpful
with keeping-- anybody
who has a biological
interest in those
offspring help them grow.
And in fact, anthropologists
are now showing that our
increase in intelligence is
largely related to this very
important family structure,
that if a child has
consistent--
consistent is the key word, not
a new nanny fired every
week because you don't
like her--
OK, consistent primary
attachment figures.
A young baby has to learn how
to decode different people's
ways and expressions when
they're pre-verbal.
So that decoding process while
the brain is tripling in size
in the first year of life is
actually the big intelligent
explosion of humans.
So we lived in these
encampments.
We really didn't see many
non-biologically related people.
Except, oh, yeah, those hunters,
the odd hunter, the
3% player, the Don Juan.
He's meant to be in this
culture, too, for a reason.
So he would travel a little
further with his little pack,
and, trying to look for woolly
mammoth, oh, he'd stumble on
our village.
And all of a sudden, all the
women would sit up and take
notice, because there was
pheromones that smelled a lot
different than their brother.
OK, so let's talk a little bit
about how anthropologists
decide whether a certain primate
species is monogamous,
promiscuous, or something
in between.
AUDIENCE: Testicle size?
WENDY WALSH: Yeah, very good.
It's scrotum size.
So basically, we look at scrotum
size in relation to
body weight.
So at one end of the scale,
you've got the orangutan--
big, hulking body, teeny
little nuts--
very paternal, very
monogamous.
At the other end, you've
got the chimpanzee.
I don't think you can take
a picture of a chimpanzee
without showing his balls,
they're so big.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: Tiny, little,
fast-moving body, huge,
enormous gonads--
very promiscuous.
So what do you think
human beings are?
We're somewhere in the middle.
Because we have it all.
We have it all.
We have, some people would say,
a system of perceived
monogamy, or culturally imposed
monogamy, or some natural--
serial monogamy.
In fact, because our life is so
long now, most people will
see at least two very long term
stints of monogamy in
their life span.
When "till death do us
part" was invented,
death was pretty imminent.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: So we'll probably
see long stints of monogamy.
But, yeah.
So this is why, in America
today, if we're looking at
paternal investment in one's
offspring, you are going to
see a guy who's only investment
in his offspring is
one teaspoon of sperm at the
one end of the scale.
And at the other end of the
scale, you're going to see a
baby-wearing, carpool-driving,
softball-throwing, doting dad,
and everything in between.
I happen to live in a
neighborhood that's a
wonderful--
I live in Playa Vista, a little
bedroom community, and
it's filled with small
children and babies.
And I would say that at least
30% are stay-at-home dads.
I don't know if they are working
from home offices.
But they line up those little
strollers by the basketball
courts in the morning-- it's
pretty hysterical-- and they
get their game in.
I'm like, don't let the ball hit
the pink stroller, please.
OK, but I mentioned
attachment.
My area of interest is an area
of psychology called
attachment theory.
It's the ways human beings
attach across a lifespan.
And specifically, the mass
media talks about
mother-infant attachment,
father-infant attachment,
because we know that that is
the foundation for healthy
personality development.
And it eventually translates
into a healthy love
relationship in adult life.
So a healthy attachment means
that you've got caregivers who
are responsive to a child's
needs, and they help create
emotional intelligence,
feelings of security.
When a baby is not stressing
about when mom's coming back
or because their diaper is wet
or they're crying because they
need food, guess what?
They're having this moment
of quiet looking
out into the world.
And their brain is growing
synapses like crazy as they're
able to learn.
If a baby lives stressed, not
feeling safe, they don't grow
as much in intelligence.
So attachment is primary.
It leads to intellectual
intelligence, as I mentioned,
less anxiety, depression,
personality disorders.
Attachment is now being linked
to so much stuff that's
happening later in life.
And more than anything, the
thing I care about is that it
becomes a blueprint for love
that transfers eventually to
adult relationships.
This is one of the pictures that
was taken last week of
this new tribe they
found in Peru.
They're all over Google
right now.
They're really great pictures.
This is what our biology
is wired for,
to live near nature.
And there's a psychologist
in Canada--
I'm Canadian, so I love
to quote this guy.
I think his book is called "Last
Child in the Woods." And
he coined a new diagnosis that
he calls Nature Deficit
Disorder in children, and they
are associating with ADD,
ADHD, anxiety issues,
et cetera.
So we're meant to be surrounded
by nature.
This is what our biology
is wired for.
We're meant to be with a very
safe, secure group of not more
than 30, 35 people.
And every once in awhile, you
get a new hunter, or you meet
with another band of
30, 35 people.
And you say, oh, that's probably
only my third cousin.
I think that'd be fine, right?
And that's how we made it.
This is what we are wired for.
But this is what our biology
is responding to--
crowded subways, crowded
nightclubs,
crowded digital worlds.
So imagine your biology now
responding to all these
objects, pheromones, cues that a
new hunter has walked in, or
you ventured on a new place
with new young--
but our biology is
going crazy.
Because actually, sex with
somebody who you weren't
related to was a trace
nutrient in our
anthropological past.
I make the comparison between
the slow food movement.
Sugar, salt, and fat were vital
but trace nutrients in
our anthropological past.
Our smart corporations realize
that we have an unsatiated
craving for salt,
sugar, and fat.
So they put it into absolutely
everything
to make us get addicted.
So the slow love movement, which
I'm going to be talking
to you about, is very much like
the slow food movement.
Remember, this is what
we're wired for.
This was taken with a long
range telescope.
And this is this new tribe in
Peru that I can't pronounce
the name of.
This is really what
we're wired for.
And this is what we have.
This is what we need--
high nutrition relationships
that are good for our biology,
that are good for our
psychology, and, more than
anything, good for
our offspring.
Of course, the answer
is to charge the
highest price for sex.
And that price is care
and commitment.
I was holding a lot of focus
groups for my book, because I
pulled up all the research-- and
by the way, I didn't start
out to write a book called
"The 30 Day Love Detox--
don't have sex for 30 days, or
you're going to break up." I
set out to write a book about
Love 2.0, Love 3.0.
I want to pull all the
research and see
what's going on.
And the research spoke
to me, and I started
pulling in focus groups.
And that's how I met Marty.
Thank you very much.
Marty was at one of my original
focus groups when I
was researching my book.
AUDIENCE: You knew me
from somewhere.
WENDY WALSH: I pulled in groups
of women, and I just
asked them to talk to me about
their dating lives and what
was going on.
And what I discovered is that a
lot of women-- because we're
going back to the beginning
now-- who believe that we're
in this high supply sexual
economy, where every guy's a
player and every woman should
comply, are signing up for
these low criteria relationships
that don't
actually suit their biology.
A low criteria relationship is
one where they text a lot.
They meet for dinner and sex
every once in awhile.
Their families haven't met.
They haven't ever talked
about a future.
And, oh, they forgot to mention
sexual exclusivity.
So these are the low criteria
relationships that are
existing today.
And they work great for guys, by
the way, with no fertility
window, and it's
not a problem.
But to actually take
the time--
Now, here are the myths that I
came up with that are really
keeping people single.
The first is this idea that we
talked about already, that the
hookup culture is everywhere
and everybody's doing it.
It's not.
The media is selling you
products using sex and selling
you reality shows using lots
of hook-up sex to get your
eyeballs there, because this
was trace nutrients in our
anthropological past.
This idea that women have
sexual needs-- women's
sexuality is very responsive,
meaning that women's biology
gets geared up when they meet
someone they're interested in.
All of a sudden everything
gets charged up
and they get excited.
But when that interest goes
away, everything calms down
and gets suppressed
for a while.
Women don't tend to replace
their boyfriend with
pornography and masturbation.
That's a guy thing.
Guys do that.
Women, it just goes away.
And then they meet someone else
they're interested in,
and it all charges up again.
But what I hear a lot of women
say today, because, again,
they've been adopting a male
model of sexuality, is, well,
what about my needs?
What about my sexual needs?
Well, when you look at the
research, plenty of women have
sex because they're
actually looking--
sometimes they have a desire
to be desired.
Sometimes they just want
closeness and companionship.
So the sexual act is something
that they will do because
they're getting all those
other things.
So when I hear about, what
about my sexual needs?
I always say, you know, guys
are a little different.
Guys are wired to be a little
more like basic plumbing--
clean the pipes every
once in a while.
And every guy's different--
sometimes it's once a day,
once a month, twice
a week, whatever.
Everybody's got their thing.
They use their girlfriend.
They use their hand.
They use their porn.
Did you know--
I'm telling you guys this-- one
third of all content on
the internet is porn.
Which is causing a whole other
problem for guys, because,
again, that's junk food sex.
So it's desensitizing them.
They're having trouble with
real, live, warm-bodied women.
Because it's not a new
visual stimulation.
What makes long term monogamy
work is a very
rich fantasy life.
And porn disables your fantasy
life because you're being fed
new images all the time.
OK, this is the one that people
always ask me about.
Well, what about sexual
chemistry?
You've got to make sure you've
got that sexual chemistry.
Like somehow winning the husband
lottery is what you're
trying to do.
If you just hit on enough,
eventually you'll go, oh!
It's perfect.
Well, actually, one study of
more than 2,000 couples showed
that the hotter the sexual
chemistry early on, the worse
the relationship outcomes--
the more breakups, the
more fighting.
Because sex is a trick.
What it does is your body is
overwhelmed with hormones, and
your neurotransmitters are
on fire with excitement.
It's not unlike heroin,
in fact.
So while you're on this heroin
high of dopamine, [INAUDIBLE],
you literally are not making
decisions about whether this
person would be a good
partner for you.
You're saying, they're perfect
because I'm orgasming.
They're perfect.
I'm getting off.
It's great.
And then, when your body starts
to get accustomed to
the dopamine hits, you go, oh,
now who are they again?
What was that about?
And then you say, well, we just
didn't have chemistry,
and you move on.
Actually, studies of long-term
married people, and even
arranged marriages, shows that
sexual chemistry is something
that's fashioned.
It's fashioned out of intimacy,
emotional intimacy,
where can actually say,
here's who I am.
I'm not necessarily part
of the hook-up culture.
I'm part of this, or I like to
do this, or I like to do that.
But if you don't have emotional
intimacy, you can't
even talk about it, right?
And the last one, this idea that
sex leads to love that I
talk about.
Sometimes for women, sex
does lead to love.
But it rarely does for men.
You know what?
Men don't fall in love
through sex.
Men fall in love
through trust.
And because of the sexual double
standard, they don't
really trust women
who are easy.
So it's a crazy catch-22 that
women are being forced into.
And finally, this idea that
promiscuity can be turned off.
Do you know how often I hear
people say, look, I'm doing
this for now, but when I settle
down, I'm just going to
settle down.
I would venture to say that
every relationship you have in
your life is a training ground
for every relationship you're
going to have in your future.
And the only way to train for
monogamy is to abstain or be
monogamous, actually.
Because you're setting yourself
up for needing more
variety of stimuli.
So I hope I've been able to
explain to you how the slow
love movement is a lot like
the slow food movement.
When Carlos Petrini, the chef
who started the slow food
movement in Italy, when he saw
the McDonald's go up near the
famous Spanish Steps in Rome and
finally put his foot down
and said, enough.
We will return to the
family table.
We will have slow food.
We will not have mass-produced,
high-technology
food, and started this
slow food movement.
And we've started to
see little farmers'
markets crop up.
The beginning of that, they
all thought we were nuts.
They thought we were a bunch
of hippies, in the '80s and
'90s, growing our food
and being organic.
Well, now what do we know
about nutrition?
We realize that high-tech,
mass-produced food is not what
we should be taking
into our body.
And the same thing
with high-tech,
mass-produced junk food sex.
Farmers' markets, in my mind,
equals the kind of close,
emotional, loving, supportive
intimacy that
we want in our lives.
And so I came up with this
idea of slow love.
Oh, and by the way, my book
is called "The 30 Day Love
Detox," because one study I
found showed that if you have
sex within 30 days of meeting
somebody, you've got about a
90% chance of being broken
up within one year.
If you wait only 31 to 90 days,
the stats go to about
25% that you'll still
be together.
But what does it mean?
It means that you're building
some kind of friendship, some
kind of connection before the
onset of the heroin that
you're going to do.
So slow love--
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: --is about
purging low nutrition
relationships.
The other thing I've noticed
that people do to satisfy
themselves emotionally while
they're in one of those low
criteria relationships, the
one that's just mostly
text-based and meet for dinner
and sex, is they keep their
self-esteem by having a bunch
of other partners online.
When I say partners, I mean
potential partners.
They've got Facebook friends.
They've got Twitter.
They've kept in touch with their
high school sweetheart.
They've got maybe ex.
They've got somebody
at the office.
Part of purging low nutrition
relationships includes purging
all those digital relationships
that are not
really bringing you emotional
sustenance.
And then delaying the onset of
sex with a new partner--
I could not find any research to
show that waiting too long
was too long.
Also for my book, I interviewed
these born again
virgins, men and women who
decided to opt out of the high
supply sexual economy and
just say, mmm, it's
really not for me.
I'm going to wait until
I find someone.
And I also interviewed former
virgins who were now married,
nursing babies.
One woman was a Harvard MBA
Wall Street broker, and
dressed sexy as anybody else.
And I said, hah!
I wanted to know, how
do you say no?
How can you say no?
You're looking hot.
You're going out on dates
with same guys.
How can you, when the pressure
comes on-- and what I heard
over and over from women is
that when you are so sure
inside yourself, men and women,
that this is what you
want for your health, that it's
really easy to say no.
Because you're not even
pressured that much.
But this one 25-year-old MBA
virgin, I asked her, so what
do you do when a guy says, oh,
come on, I'm going to get it
from somebody.
I might as well get
it from you.
I mean, you know I'm going to
go out there and get it.
So come on, you and I, we've
been dating for a while.
And she said, oh, I love
it when they say that.
I just say, actually, I don't
think you can get sex with me
from someone else.
So the point is she
values herself.
I know a college student
girl who--
the pressure line from the guy
was, I don't think I should
have to work for sex.
And she said, I'm not sex.
I'm Sheryl.
Right?
So it's about understanding
what's going on
and where you fit.
The other thing is to make sure
that you are brave enough
to ask for sexual exclusivity.
Isn't it amazing that although,
as I say, 20%
percent of men may be able to
obtain sex on a first date,
80% of women are smart enough
not to expose their eggs and
their bloodstream to somebody
they wouldn't even give the
keys to their apartment to to
water their plants while
they're out of town, right?
So we get into these sexual
relationships, and plenty of
people are afraid to ask for
exclusivity when STDs are
running rampant in
our culture.
It's so simple to just ask.
The "what are we" conversation
is so difficult
for people to have.
And then, of course, to make
sure you use the F word, which
are "feelings." How do
you feel about this?
What's going on?
And to practice intellectual
commitment.
Now, what is intellectual
commitment?
Love and sex are what happens
at the beginning of a
relationship.
But once all the hormones die
down, then it becomes an
intellectual commitment.
And that's when I hear people
say all the time, well, I want
to keep my options open.
Or, I want to just--
later I'll be-- and I'm just
like, no, why don't you make
an intellectual commitment like
you do in an exercise
program, to a diet?
See what happens.
See what you learn, even if
you're just practicing
emotional intimacy.
Because here's why.
It's very well researched--
long-term, monogamous bonded
people actually have higher
life expectancies.
They live longer.
AUDIENCE: How do you control?
How do you be sure?
WENDY WALSH: Do you know
Dan Buettner's
work "The Blue Zones"?
Anybody read "The Blue Zones"?
It's these five areas on the
planet they call blue zones
where a disproportionate amount
of people live to be
over the age of 100.
And then he looks for
commonalities between these
five areas--
and long-term married
partners.
None of the men over 100
have been playboys.
They have like one wife
taking care of them.
Actually, health-wise, monogomy
benefits men more
than women, believe it or not.
Women's health goes down just a
little bit, because they're
doing double duty.
Men tend to have much better
health if they're in a
relationship.
Long-term married people of
course accumulate more wealth.
Do you know how expensive
divorce is?
Or maintaining two houses
with a baby mama
and a bunch of kids?
Or two baby mamas?
Yeah.
Putting it all in one big pot
and planning for the future.
Their offspring do a
whole lot better.
I always say this to young
men when I see them out
at parties and stuff.
I go, OK, here's a little
quiz for you.
If your choice tonight is to
hook up with five women and
hope that three of them have
your babies, and you never see
them again, or you find one
woman and stay with her for 20
years and two kids and put them
through college, where
are your genes going to be in
five generations from now?
Are your genes going to stay
in evolution's chain?
I think this is the
better way.
OK, I'll close it with
by the numbers.
Average lifetime number of
sexual partners by gender--
this is a new study for Centers
for Disease Control
that came out in 2009.
Now, here's what you
should know.
AUDIENCE: This must be median.
WENDY WALSH: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: The mean
has to be equal.
WENDY WALSH: No.
Here's why.
I love having bright
people in the room.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: Even on anonymous
sexual surveys, men lie up and
women lie down.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so
these are lies.
These aren't actual--
AUDIENCE: Reported.
WENDY WALSH: These
are reported.
OK, yes, so your mean answer
is five, right?
It's probably five.
This is a Centers for Disease
Control study of more than
6,000 people.
And this is age 18 to 44.
So it's not over--
middle age is not encompassed
there.
And by the way, anything I've
talked about today, please
feel free to contact me.
I've got all the references and
the studies if you want to
look into them a
little further.
And they're all in my reference
section of my book, too.
I think some of you are going
to get a copy of the book.
OK, so now I want you to
understand that if the mean is
5, the number of people who have
had sex with more than 15
people is 27% men
and 10% women.
Again, men lie up and brag,
women lie down.
So I don't know, maybe
it's 15%, 17%.
Yeah.
So that's also pulling that
number, that 6 and 4.
That still brings in that 27%
of men who have 15 or more.
So even to say that the average
lifetime partners is 5
for men is even a little high.
AUDIENCE: Do you think the men
with a lot of sexual partners
actually lie down, and
the average lie up?
WENDY WALSH: That's
a good point.
But in general, the way our
culture is, men tend to over--
yeah, but you're right.
So you're saying, once they hit
a certain point, even they
know that, culturally, having
300 partners is not cool.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: So they'll start
to take it to 30, right?
But my favorite study is the
number of men who would prefer
a romantic date over
a hook up is 75%.
Women are always surprised
by this number.
Is there any man in this room
who can help explain to the
women why this number
is this number?
Is there any man who would
prefer a romantic date to a
hook-up in this room?
AUDIENCE: One is very--
it's over, and that's it.
WENDY WALSH: And so a romantic
date could lead to--
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: --well consistent,
frequent sex.
It also could lead to all the
other things-- a relationship.
Oh, God forbid.
It could actually lead to all
the social support that you
need, that accumulation of
wealth, the better health, and
everything else.
So even men like romance
and like slow love.
But women feel that somehow--
in fact, when that population
of women who've adopted the
male model of sexuality, they're
actually not adopting
a male model of sexuality.
They're adopting the
three-percenter.
Because that's what they know.
That's been the most
obvious to them.
So if you love better, you
can actually live better.
And there's all my contact.
And let's start with
some questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much
for this talk.
It was very, very interesting.
Thanks, Marty, for putting
this together.
I had one comment and
one question.
My comment is I used to teach
sex health in college.
And I feel like so many students
would benefit from
seeing these numbers when they
first enter into college.
Because as you said, the
media's totally off.
And I grew up watching "Friends"
before going to
college, and I was like, oh,
everybody's just in bed with
each other all the time.
[LAUGHS]
WENDY WALSH: I actually have an
answer of how you all can
help me with that.
Marty very kindly has a camera
here for a reason.
I'm going to use part of this as
an audition tape for NACA,
National Association of Campus
Activities, to audition to get
on the college circuit.
So I should put a link up.
If anyone emails me any quote
about this talk that's
positive, I'll put
it on my flyer.
Yeah, I'll put anything you
can give me positive.
And you're always welcome to
go and refer me for a TED
Talk, just saying.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: It's online.
You just fill it in.
Go ahead.
What's your question?
AUDIENCE: And then another
thing-- you refer to the whole
economic background of this.
I definitely believe it's an
exchange, and there's lots of
sex economics going on.
But I think a major part of
economics is understanding the
marginal utilities and being
open about your functions.
So I feel like everybody might
not be within these numbers or
these ranges or anything
like that.
But I think a very important
thing along with slow love is
just open and honest love,
like from the beginning--
WENDY WALSH: Exactly!
AUDIENCE: What you're looking
for, what you want.
Sometimes the men want something
that traditionally a
woman would want.
Sometimes the woman
wants something--
WENDY WALSH: Yeah, I think there
are as many men who are
afraid to say, I want
a relationship.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah, and I think you can have
completely healthy hook-up
relationships where a woman gets
what she needs because
that's what she needs
at that given time.
But what she needs might
change later on.
WENDY WALSH: And then,
unfortunately, it sometimes
biologically changes because of
the biological changes that
happen-- either she's
starting to feel
bonded because of the--
I interviewed so many people
for this book.
And some of them said, here's
the thing about hook-ups.
It always starts out fun, until
somebody gets hurt.
Because eventually, one person
likes the other person more.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And that's, I think, when maybe
you're not being honest
to yourself about how your
utility function has changed.
WENDY WALSH: Yeah, the
first person to be
honest with is yourself.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah, so I think it would be
really cool, how you built the
basic economic thing, if you
extrapolate out to how
people's functions can be
different and how they change
over a lifetime, and how what
you look for is different, and
that might lead to serial
monogamy and
that kind of thing.
WENDY WALSH: The two times where
men and women need each
other the most are when they are
raising offspring who are
very small children, the zero
to 10, or zero to to 12, and
my age, as we get older,
and we're looking for
companionship to settle
down with, as health
problems start to happen.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
WENDY WALSH: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: What effect do you
think STDs had in early human
sexual development?
WENDY WALSH: Well, I'm only
guessing, but I would say that
in the early sexual development,
STDs--
because, again, these are small
populations of people.
So if they came like any other
disease, if they came through,
they wiped out a group.
Remember, at one point there
were 27 humanoid species
living together, and some of
them mixing and mating even.
So that's even separate
from the other
four primate species.
So plenty of them got knocked
out along the way as we zeroed
down into one.
And STDs were one way.
Lots of other diseases, too.
AUDIENCE: So how did that affect
how people are now?
WENDY WALSH: So you're thinking
it might have most
knocked out the people who were
the most promiscuous?
Is that your guess?
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if that's true.
Maybe.
WENDY WALSH: I don't know.
Does that sound like
it could have been?
I think that if we stayed
too 100% monogamous--
although, there are plenty
of species that are 100%
monogamous, and they tend to
procreate and do just fine.
But I think what was important
for humans is that we had the
three-percenter who wandered
so that we could mix up the
gene pool as much as possible.
You know about the Swiss
t-shirt study, right?
The smelling of pheromones?
OK, so the Swiss t-shirt study
is where they put a bunch of
men and asked them to
sleep in the same--
they each had their own--
t-shirt every night
for 14 nights.
And then they put it in a Ziploc
bag every morning to
lock in the freshness.
And at the end of a couple
weeks, they had a panel of
women just smell the t-shirts.
And what they found is, the
pheromones that the women
found most attractive were
those that had the most
disparate immune systems.
Because when you mate with
somebody, you take one gene
from another and another from
another, so that you've got
blue eyes from one, and long
legs from another, and brown
hair from another, et cetera.
Except immune systems--
they combine.
So we can actually sniff out
when people have immune
systems that are too
similar to us.
That's why our brothers
smell so nasty to us.
Honestly, they do.
I remember growing up, thinking,
guys, take a shower.
But I didn't notice it
with other guys.
And what else was I going
to say about STDs?
So in the same sense, I think
along the way, people have
been using all kinds of ways to
attract mates separate and
aside from just visual.
Visual's a big one for men.
And women most vote for
intelligence and kindness over
looks, by the way, you guys.
So don't worry about your
hair or worry about
how funny you are.
Because it's connected
to intelligence, too.
AUDIENCE: You could
have funny hair.
WENDY WALSH: You could
That would be great.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: Anyway--
AUDIENCE: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: You said that a lot
of the stuff that you say is
not politically correct, which
is probably like the
understatement of the--
WENDY WALSH: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Do you have the
Women's Studies department
parked out across your office
with torches and forks.
WENDY WALSH: The true feminists
understand that true
feminine, female sexual freedom
is to have choice.
And I don't actually
say there's one
right way to do anything.
I can give you statistical
probabilities.
I can tell you a little bit
about your biology.
By the way, the more sexual
partners a man has had, the
more likely he is to perceive
diminished attractiveness in
each new mate.
So it's a race to the
bottom for him.
Every new woman rolls over
easy, it disappoints him.
This was a big study
out of UCLA.
The more sexual partners a woman
has had, the more likely
she is to be on an
antidepressant.
Now, it could be working
in reverse.
Depressed women could be using
sex to self-medicate.
We don't necessarily assume
causality there.
But we look at all this, and
we look at the picture of
what's going on, and we listen
to our own bodies, our own
souls, and we ask for what
nutrition is out there.
I wrote a blog a couple--
and you're all welcome to
subscribe to my blog.
I send out a weekly
newsletter.
AUDIENCE: Or your
YouTube channel.
WENDY WALSH: My YouTube
channel, of course!
I wrote a blog about how
I really have this new,
enlightened thinking that the
Muslim hijab is actually a
great act of female
sexual freedom.
Because I spent a
month in London.
I talked to a lot of Muslim
women, these young, hot girls
working at Starbucks
with their hijab.
And I would just talk to
them about who they
were, and very modern.
And they said, listen, you guys
think you've got female
sexual freedom, and you are
doing Brazilian waxes,
vajazziling, bleaching your
anus, all to please men and
the porn industry?
Like, that's female
sexual freedom?
And I looked at them, and I
thought, you know what?
This whole idea of choosing to
be modest, nothing put on
them-- nobody says on Oxford
Street, you've got to wear a
hijab, right?
So the choice to be
modest is power.
It's female power.
And there was a feminist who I
quoted in my blog who said,
bearing your breasts on YouTube
isn't necessarily
female power.
Neither is wearing a hijab.
What's female power is being
able to have the choice.
And that's freedom, to
understand all the various
choices available to you.
AUDIENCE: So you answered the
question of why it is that
feminists should not
be angry with you.
WENDY WALSH: Oh, but are
some of them angry?
AUDIENCE: I don't think you're
politically incorrect.
I think, from a woman's
standpoint,
you're spot on, actually.
WENDY WALSH: I think teaching
women to understand their
biology and respect it and
empower them to live out their
biology is good.
I do have a few women, usually
the undergraduates at the
university level who are
very pro-fem, they'll
walk out the back.
I'll watch them go, [SIGHS],
close their
books, and walk out.
And then there'll be a few
that'll stay later for the
chitchat who will be like, so
I've been hooking up with this
guy for a while, thought
he was my boyfriend.
And I just saw on Facebook
that my friend
slept with him, and--
[PRETENDS TO CRY]
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: I'm like, did you
ever have a talk with him
about exclusivity?
So it's just a matter of being
authentic with ourselves and
our feelings and being able
to talk to people.
I know you guys are in the tech
business, and it's all
about [TYPING NOISES]
now.
But I do say that when you
have a relationship with
somebody by text, whether
it's business, whatever
relationship, it's like
listening to your favorite
band without the drummer
or the lead singer.
So you're missing a lot.
When we communicate,
we have visual.
We have body language.
You've got vocal tone.
You're smelling me.
We've got pheromones.
Your brain is taking in so much
information right now.
But when you're [TYPING NOISES],
you're
actually putting yourself on.
That's why people fall
into catfishes.
Because they are projecting
their own needs, loves, and
desires on to the computer.
And they get just enough back
that they think it's real.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a
little bit more about--
you were saying women
aren't allowing
themselves to be mothers.
I think that's a
very complex--
so there's socially
we've changed.
Biologically we haven't
changed.
All the women who are graduating
ahead of men, we go
for our careers, and then--
WENDY WALSH: I know exactly
what you're saying.
OK, right now, there's a book
you have to read that I love
called "Reshaping the
Work Family Debate--
Why Men and Social Class
Matter." It's by Joan--
ah--
up at UC Hastings law school.
OK, she wrote this amazing book,
saying, our problem is
right now we are not preparing
women for motherhood.
We have failed them in our push
to push girls forward and
push girls into higher
education.
I have a high school-age girl.
In ninth grade, they sent them
out a college application,
told the kids to fill it out,
look for the holes, and start
filling them in in the
next three years.
My kid is 15 years old.
She has no interest in going
to hang out in the mall and
pick out boys.
She wants to go tour colleges
on every vacation we take.
I'm like, you've got to stop.
You've got to have fun.
You've got to be a teenager.
AUDIENCE: And globalization--
WENDY WALSH: Right, they're
pushing these girls, pushing
these girls like crazy.
She's all concerned about her
GPA, and she's crying in the
bathtub if it's not 4.0.
And I'm like, stop.
AUDIENCE: And boys, too.
WENDY WALSH: Go smoke some
weed and meet a boy.
Yeah, exactly.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: But honestly, I
never thought as a mother that
I'd be thinking that
to my daughter.
I didn't say it.
I'm thinking it.
I've also said to my daughter,
listen, I know you watch "Teen
Mom" on MTV-- and by the way, my
friend Jared in the back--
Jared and Jordan,
the two J's--
produce for MTV.
They do the VMAs.
and they produce "Teen Mom." and
I was like, listen, to my
daughter, if you watch teen mom,
and you have a teenage
pregnancy, you are so going
to be grounded.
And I'm so going to
take that baby.
Because I'm afraid--
the whole problem here is--
I'm not going to get to
be a grandmother.
That's really what
it's about, OK?
So the answer is, if you look
at more developed countries
like us, like Sweden and
Iceland, they have very
powerful women.
They have more babies
born out of wedlock.
But what they have are the
social supports that
we don't have here.
The problem is this--
the single mother walk--
we don't have the social
supports advanced enough.
So the single mother
walk is a hard one.
I'm in it.
I've been single for eight
years; I've got two kids.
Let me tell you, single mothers
in America today have
their own worse mental health,
worse physical health.
Their kids have worse
physical health.
Their kids have lower academic
grades, earlier onset of
sexual behavior, and more sex,
drugs, rock and roll,
basically, OK?
We do not have any
social support.
So when I see the government
trying to push this whole bill
to provide preschools, at least
that's some child care.
14 million single mothers are
raising one in four American
children right now--
one in four.
And it's only going up, because
women are not choosing
marriage, or men are not using
marriage, or their children
have divorced, themselves.
We have a second generation now
of divorced people who are
terrified of it.
So the answer is a very
complicated one that has to
not only involve personal
decision, not only in how we
raise our girls, but also in
looking at our culture as a
whole, and what we can do
to support single parent
families, whether it be a man
or a woman raising the kids.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's tough.
You know, you're asking women
to basically look to try to
have babies at 25, 26, 27, 28.
But for men who are ready,
who are genetically--
WENDY WALSH: Interestingly
enough, research shows that a
girl who has a baby during
college or right after college
takes less of a financial
hit than if she takes a
big time off at 35.
Because she's not making
much then.
And she's young enough to hop
back on the treadmill.
When you're 35 and you're making
$250,000 a year and you
take two years off to stay with
the baby, it's a whole
different thing.
AUDIENCE: And also you're
commitments--
you're paying a much higher
mortgage at that point.
WENDY WALSH: Everything, yeah.
It's so much harder.
Exactly.
AUDIENCE: But then coming back
into it at the age--
WENDY WALSH: I'll tell you, one
of the changes we can make
right away--
everybody in this culture stop
using the word "maternity
leave." It's paternal leave.
It's paternity--
or sorry, it's parental leave.
Sorry.
As soon as we call it parental
leave and men get into the
game and think they have
equal access to
these benefits, then--
AUDIENCE: Google has a great
maternity leave.
WENDY WALSH: But what about the
guy who wants to stay home
and take care of the kids?
And what if she wants
to charge back?
Until it becomes gender equal,
until the care of children
becomes gender equal and it's
instituted at the corporate
level, then--
I'm Canadian.
So in Canada, you get a year
off, father or mother, paid at
80% of your salary.
Because they have socialized
medicine, and they've learned
that if you breastfeed those
babies, you reduce your health
care costs by so much.
AUDIENCE: I know, but that
makes sense, you see.
WENDY WALSH: Yeah,
there's a number.
AUDIENCE: That makes sense, so
we're not going to do it.
You're trying to make sense--
WENDY WALSH: Oh, of course!
We don't want to make sense.
OK.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I just don't see
Americans ever getting there.
Drug companies alone.
WENDY WALSH: But you guys
have the power.
You're our future.
You're young Americans
who have a
voice, you're out there.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: [LAUGHS]
OK, I got a peer over here.
I'm still older than
you, I promise.
AUDIENCE: I wouldn't bet.
WENDY WALSH: I would bet.
How old are you?
AUDIENCE: 51.
WENDY WALSH: Oh, we're peers.
I'm 51, too.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: We'll hook up later.
WENDY WALSH: OK.
[LAUGHING]
WENDY WALSH: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Dr. Walsh, thank you
so much for being here today.
That's for you.
And guys, if you want your
book signed, we have some
Sharpies in the back.
I think we might have
run out of books.
But thank you guys so
much for coming.
And thanks for joining us.
WENDY WALSH: Do I get
a Google t-shirt?
Oh, yay!
[APPLAUSE]